i'm back with juliana margolis give it
up y'all
all right it's another rad mama hour
again um there are a few things that are
guaranteed during
any mama celebration here on the kelly
clarkson show good times crazy stories
unexpected confessions
wine and our next guest because i love
them
you know them from their hit podcast and
web series i mom so hard
they have a new children's book meanest
of the meanies
i love y'all out right now please
welcome kristen hinsley and jim smedley
everybody
hi how are you doing ladies
we are great we're happy to be here i'm
trying to make sure kristen stays on
this couch and away from i just want to
be so close to both of you
and i keep getting further away and i
know that's because i'm a slight
security risk but i'm chilling
i'm really far away from yeah you guys
are gonna
put me on the side and the next time
you're gonna be with the band that's
fine
that'd be awesome so you've been you've
been busy since i last saw you so tell
us about your new children's book i love
the title meanest of the meanies
so is it about me and kids well they can
be mean they don't mean to be but
they're honest
that's not always great um but it's just
the idea that no matter what you do as a
mom
your kid views it as something you're
doing that's mean or uncool or you're
stopping their fun
and all you're trying to do is build a
decent human you know and the only way
they're gonna thank you is someday when
they have kids but that's a long time
from now
so we figured we'd write a children's
book and celebrate among our
our mom crowd yeah um
so every mom in our house seats can
obviously
you know relate to the highs and lows
hilarity and humiliation
of trying to raise our kids right that's
why we'd love to invite everyone in our
audience to
wine to mommy this
is a safe space to laugh cry commiserate
um
so are you ready for this you've never
done this with us before i've never done
this i'm a little nervous
she just every time somebody reaches
front she's like sure yeah let's do it
totally a third of this um so let's get
to the sharing uh
starting with raven so raven first of
all congratulations your little one is
almost here right almost here thank you
hi how are you guys oh my god you are so
beautiful you're so cute
um thank you so so what's going on with
you
okay kelly so i'm 35 weeks pregnant this
is
our first child me my husband are
expecting uh we're just so excited for
her to be here so soon and i see her
little sweet face so we're so excited
but since the beginning of this
pregnancy we have been getting
advice from everybody all the time every
day
um some people are saying that we need
to rock our baby because
that's how you consult and bond your
baby and then others say no
never let it rock them let those cry it
out so that they get comfortable kind of
consoling themselves
um we've had people even say something
crazy like if we want her to walk early
then we have to have her in shoes all
the time um or even if i'm having crazy
heartburn it's gotta be because my baby
has a ton of hair
uh so kelly we just want to know will we
constantly be
bombarded with all these questions all
the time even after
our baby girl gets here oh yes yes
yes and that was so annoying too when i
was people are trying to be helpful i
get it
but i was like look i'm not gonna be
that mom that's like
she has a tutor and she's getting into
harvard and she's gonna like i'm not
like i'm not
i'm not that mom like it's not she's
gonna end up there if she wants to be
there like it's like
let your baby walk when they're supposed
to walk let your baby sleep
do it how you want i will say now that
i've said that
the one thing i did listen to was a book
called 12 hours by 12 weeks
okay and it's the only thing i listened
to everybody i read books i did things
like with my first child and i was so
worried
that really did help it was the one
advice i will say that changed my life
the sleep training thing
but at the same time do whatever is
natural for you and feels good for
for you and your man like it's like it's
whatever you want it to be it's it's
going to be that way
i think anyway is fine yeah yeah i think
you have to i mean for
for me you know i i felt like it was
really important for my child to feel
safe in his own room and his own bed
and also i was newly wed so i didn't
want him in our bed with us like i felt
like that wasn't a good
thing um and so it was great he loves
his bed he loves his room but then when
i'd want to like just take a nap
with him he was not interested in coming
into my bed so it's like
just find your way you know i i feel
like i do know a lot of my
friends who let their kids sleep in
their bed uh then couldn't get them out
of the bed
i say no to that so i i just wasn't
interested in that because i think
you know happy parents happy baby yes
um and i think that's more important
personally yeah
it feels like everybody always has
advice and things to tell a pregnant
woman like we don't have
we're just open to it i say just be
polite and ignore everybody
but i i was at trader joe's and
this guy was helping me with my
groceries no i didn't know his name so i
looked at his price
at his name tag but he felt he could
tell me where i needed to put
olive oil right before i delivered the
baby
what turns out olive oil can go
in pasta and various parts of your
orphanage
of your orifices and i thought to myself
have have you
any idea that also that sounds like an
awesome idea i did listen to him a
little bit but
at the end of the day i was like you're
not my ob gyn you're just a guy at
trader joe's but you feel like you're
comfortable enough to tell me this very
graphic
birth story we always think that like
the most important
piece of advice that you should be told
by like other moms should clue you in on
is uh the first poop oh yeah and we're
not talking about the babies we're
talking about yours after delivery
no one tells you that but honestly don't
scare her
you can't we're going to tell you
prepare yourself why do you think you
learn how to breathe
it's for i mean my my son was 7 4 when
he was born and that first poop was like
an eight
six hundred percent it's like yeah that
people don't warn you it is a weird
experience for your body afterwards
you're like what
my man y'all i mean actually also
invited their mamas today um this is
jesse's mama jamie hi
jamie how you doing good how you doing
i'm doing all right i've got wine jamie
so it's a good day
um i hear you send jessie's songs that
we should do on this show
oh i'm i'm a big help you know i'm a
helpful mama
yeah i i have i've seen her some that i
thought i mean the thing is
kelly you can sing anything any genre
it's just astounding and of course
this band can do anything and in a very
short
period of time so um yeah so i'm trying
to send them
some songs um i'm a big lyric fan
i love a great lyrics so i've been on
them for a while about something like
from my generation desperado you know
don henley
the beautiful kind yes also black clint
black did that
yeah oh it's it's a great song and then
another i kept thinking through this
whole last year and a half where
we've all been through so much and we've
had to learn
to be there for each other even when we
couldn't actually be there
with each other i kept thinking of that
genius
paul simon and bridge over troubled
water i mean
have we not done that such a gorgeous i
think you might have brought that up
jesse because she texted me oh okay
that's why okay
no okay i was like that's a great song
too i can't believe we haven't done that
there are so many great ones please keep
sending the songs we love the song
requests
great i'm all in yes he knows
she's got the list all right all right
those both are great let's add them
jason
um all right well thank you jamie
everybody
let's get back to this wine to mommy
session uh we have
lester's mama pat wants to join in the
discussion so pat
it's great to see you so what do you
want to talk about god
yes it's good to see you too uh
mine is more of a grandma question um
i am a proud mom and a proud grandmother
and i have 11 grandchildren and three of
which
are lesters and so
my thing is when the grandkids come
they know that there are no limits being
paw paw
will go all out of our way to make sure
they're having a good time
we go to the movies we go out to eat
we go shopping and i'm like here yeah go
ahead and buy you something
we'll take care of it don't worry and so
am i just doing a little bit too much or
should i pull back some
let me answer this yes monsters
lester's like yes you're doing too much
i say do more
and especially a good way to spoil kids
is to add to the 529
yeah that's around every time you take
them to dinner just match that in their
college fund
and then it doesn't feel so bad but like
grandparents are supposed to spoil the
grandkids
that's your way to get back at us for
when we were unruly
you know i think it's i think it's
nature
we're not going to be helpful lester
because my answer's not helpful either
because i do because here's the thing
though i i look at them because my mom
will do stuff like that too and you know
spoil them
and she loves it and she doesn't see
them as much you know so it's like okay
so but i let her do it and it's just
like i tell my kids this is not
normal this is grandma time i was like
this is not
what's gonna happen every day like this
is just the time you have with her
earned that right
yes i feel like you've earned that right
lester you're screwed 100
yeah ah i love it i love it i think
you've earned it as well
thank you so much everybody kristen and
jen's new children's book
meanest of the meanies is out right now
and look out for their
new wine line coming soon that's amazing
i you have to come back and talk about
that
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever